ah
[Música]
aquí comienza a ella soy de france24 la
corte constitucional de colombia
reconoció a mediados de mayo la partería
como un saber ancestral y un patrimonio
cultural de la nación
el alto tribunal afirmó en su sentencia
que es una manifestación de la
pluralidad de la nación y una forma de
protección de los derechos reproductivos
de las mujeres que pertenecen a las
comunidades en donde se ejerce este
saber bajo esta premisa el ministerio de
salud se vio obligado a incluir a las
parteras y parteros y asegurarlos en el
sistema de salud y de seguridad social
además el congreso debe dar los pasos
para emitir una legislación que incluya
la partería
este reconocimiento es la conclusión de
una tutela interpuesta por
organizaciones de parteras del choco y
de valle del cauca en colombia en
pandemia pese a que aumentaron los
alumbramientos fuera de los hospitales
quienes ejercen este saber no fueron
priorizados como prestadores de salud y
esto presenta una diversidad de
dificultades dicho esto hay que destacar
que esta es una práctica que está
profundamente ligada a las comunidades
afrodescendientes en colombia y por eso
vamos a tener una conversación con el
ley de manuel a mosquera quien es
partera tradicional desde hace más de 20
años y además es la directora ejecutiva
de la red de interétnica de parteras y
parteros del choco también junto a ella
están a danilo cabrera quienes aparte de
lo tradicional y miembro de la red
interétnica de parteras y parteros del
choco ambos bienvenidos gracias por
estar en ellas hoy y para comenzar que
es la partería y en qué momentos de la
maternidad se hace presente
saludos para todos y muchas gracias por
este espacio
la partería es un proceso integral de
atención materno perinatal la partería
se inicia desde digamos antes de la
gestación durante la gestación después
de la gestación y prosigue porque es un
proceso continuo dinámico estratégico
que busca
aportar a la familia a la gestante y el
recién nacido todos los cuidados todas
las acciones de protección que facilite
una mejor calidad de vida desde él desde
todo el proceso de asesoría y
acompañamiento la mujer partera o el
hombre partero como en este caso el
señor danilo estamos en todo tiempo en
la comunidad permanecemos en comunidad
sabemos qué pasa con la familia porque
de qué quiso quedar en embarazo cuando
hay dificultades y estamos allí en todo
tiempo y en todo momento
danilo porque es bueno optar por el
acompañamiento de la partería y por los
nacimientos en casa y en condiciones que
no son medicalizadas danilo
no están bloqueadas
cuando que dice la seño manera s verdad
compartir aún partes ha pasado para
salvar la vida de uno y entonces
nosotros lo vive una comunidad
descendientes pero yo cacao y haga una
lago mesa
por otro lado cuando el niño nace
entonces yo hago otro trabajito como
usted sabe en otros trabajos como
voluntariamente
todo no tenemos elementos si me tiene
como ya es costumbre los indígenas
nosotros buscábamos
remitimos sino donde ayudan a
decir que cantan
estaban nuestros 29
manuela para complementar lo que está
diciendo danilo háblenos de estos
impedimentos que tiene la partería que
está inmersa en un negocio que es el
negocio de nacer el negocio de la
maternidad de los prestadores de salud
es algo que sucede mucho en américa
latina y en colombia en general los
prestadores de salud ganan por los
partos y ganan más si esos partos son
cesárea
correcto
bueno algo muy importante
hacer en comunidades que nace con una
partera
esta es una persona que va a tener uno
un estilo de vida diferente va a ser
apegado a su territorio a su familia hay
mayores vínculos afectivos
hoy día la mujer tiene el derecho de
decidir dónde quiere la tienda su parte
pero el acompañamiento íntegro que da
una partera un partero no lo da el
centro hospitalario y aún más cuando
sabemos que es un negocio todo el tema
de la cesárea y que se practica muchas
veces muchas cesáreas innecesarias y que
hacerlo con día con la partería queremos
en ningún momento buscamos igualarnos
con médicos y enfermeras lo que buscamos
es seguir dándole esa protección al
territorio seguir en comunidad brindando
esos esos cuidados tanto a la materna
como al recién nacido y a la familia
porque la partera es la diferencia de
nacer en un hospital y nacer digamos no
tanto en casa porque pueden hacer
también en el nicho en la partida
digamos en la casa de atención de la
parte que tenemos en varios territorios
en el txoko
nacer en el territorio lo hace diferente
es porque la parte está allí la acompaña
la capacita la asesora resuelve asuntos
familiares
dirección as asuntos familiares mientras
la materna está en todo su proceso
digamos de restablecer su sistema
íntegro físico y todo lo biológico todo
lo que se vive a través del parto y algo
muy importante como decía el señor
danilo nosotros tenemos nuestra propia
ruta de atención la materna llega la
partera o el partero laxe control
verifica que está bien si se requiere
médico la pasa al médico occidental es
decir vaya haga el control para nosotros
es importante que hagan los controles
pero también hay algo muy importante que
nosotros tenemos otras creencias y otras
costumbres y la pasamos si ese indígena
va donde el hi van a que éste revise si
hay espíritus si hay drama si hay cosas
que no que la medicina occidental no va
a atender no va a tratar y si es en afro
esto pasa donde el médico tradicional y
que de una u otra forma direcciones y
dice este parto lo puede atender la
partera yo le hice a la partera no se
meta aquí realmente necesita la
asistencia médica
ahora la partera dedica su tiempo su
vida a la atención de un par
en el hospital no llegas si bueno aquí
estás preparada pasa a la sala maternas
allí esperas el médico se entretiene en
otras cosas a diferencia de la parte del
portero cuando tenemos una gestante es
esa nos dedicamos a ella bueno nos pagan
pero nosotros consideramos que hay un
pago muy grande que recibimos que es el
de la fuerza divina el del dios de los
cielos que no nos hace falta nada
independiente pero si incluso por eso
empezamos con este tema de la demanda y
agradecemos tanto el proceso de la corte
constitucional donde digamos que
favorece y respalda nuestro sentido y es
que la partera que atienda un parto se
le debe pagar iguales condiciones porque
es un trabajo igual al trabajo que está
haciendo una enfermera que está haciendo
un médico
a ellos les pagan porque pasan por una
institucionalidad pasan por la academia
pasan por baños a años de estudios pero
las partes por muchos años de estudio
desde la oralidad desde la práctica y es
practicar y practicar y apoyar a
asesorarnos buscar incluso ayuda de
otras parteras expertas que nos puedan
vivir de una u otra manera dar línea
para tener un parto tenemos claro cuando
atenderlo cuando la bebé atendemos
independiente que es indígena místico o
mestizo y hay algo del señor danilo digo
no tenemos nada pero si nos toca comprar
hasta el pañal para el recién nacido lo
compramos esa es la partida una atención
integral un proceso integral que busca
mejorar las condiciones del nacimiento
igual que las denominamos
señora perdona que la interrumpa es que
me parece importante hacer la aclaración
que igual usted lo está diciendo en su
intervención y es que la partería no va
en contra pues de la medicina
tradicional no la medicina tradicional
salvavidas eso está claro pero la
partería también está en capacidad de
salvar vidas y de hacer un
acompañamiento que aunado con la
medicina tradicional lo llámese medicina
indígena pues puede favorecer y mejorar
las condiciones de vida de esa mamá y de
ese bebé que está por nacer y que está
por llegar al mundo y ya casi estamos
llegando al final del programa pero algo
de lo que quería hablar con ustedes dos
y pues ustedes me dicen como quieren
responder en qué orden es la violencia
obstétrica
es algo aterradoramente común en los
sistemas de salud las prácticas de
romperles a las mujeres la fuente de
programar los partos de inducir los
partos a través de medicamentos que
generen contracciones cuando
probablemente no es aún el momento
natural en que el bebé debe nacer en la
instrumentalización del parto y pues
todas estas prácticas que quitan
humanidad a ese momento tan importante
que es el paso de un bebé del vientre de
su madre pues al mundo exterior como la
partería trabaja para prevenir la
violencia obstétrica
inicia con el acompañamiento desde antes
de la gestación y fuera de esto la
partería seguirá trabajando para
prevenir la violencia obstétrica
dando toda la asesoría a las madres en
qué momento
acudir al ciento al centro hospitalario
o digamos donde ya tenga el médico
occidental pero el uso de las plantas el
uso de la palabra el uso de la
naturaleza
decirle a la madre todos los cambios que
va a tener su cuerpo y que ya lo debe
aceptar y unirnos a la buena
comunicación son una de las acciones que
ayudan a prevenir la violencia estética
hay muchas mujeres cuando se acercan al
parto es cuando ya van en el proceso
total para tener su hijo de allí que
dice es que a mí me acompaña una partera
el simple hecho en la compañía una parte
de acompañar genera todas las sanciones
para prevenir la violencia estética de
allí que si en los hospitales
permitieran que las parteras estuvieran
allí acompañando se evita en granma yo
el bueno mejor dicho es fundamental que
una parte está en el centro hospitalario
porque el tiempo que la partera va a
dedicar asesorar acompañar a esperar que
ese parto llegue no es el tiempo que
tiene un médico para hacerlo y señor
danilo su conclusión bueno yo tengo nada
acompañando a las mujeres respetar a las
mujeres
respetar sus derechos de las mujeres
acompaña muy poco mujeres es un fallo
mucho
y ese es el ministro que sí señor danilo
ha sido usted más que claro un
agradecimiento a ustedes dos por estar
con nosotros de prestarnos algo de su
tiempo y hacer los desplazamientos para
poder estar en esta entrevista y pues
hoy en día no es común ver a una partera
oa un partero que asiste en un hospital
el nacimiento de un bebé pero puede ser
que en un futuro sea algo que vayamos a
ver en colombia porque ahora el congreso
de la república tiene la obligación de
legislar en esta materia y eso pues nos
lleva hacia adelante gracias a ustedes
gracias a nuestros invitados nos vemos
próximamente en ellas hoy y en france 24
[Música]